brian loftus had privileged to interview
him and he joins us live
in the studio to share some of those
moments brian thanks guys the final
episode with the game show legend of
course concluding tonight with a moving
tribute to trebek
who died november 8th of pancreatic
cancer now trebek was of course a
comforting witty and eloquent presence
in our living rooms for
three and a half decades i'd be honored
to sit down with him twice talking about
everything from his joy of hosting
to his home improvement projects even
jeopardy james
and how he thought he would fare as a
young contestant
you know what trebek you were once
that sharp you were once that fast
you were once very competitive uh at
the age of 32 i think i could have done
very well as a contestant on jeopardy
nuclear physics fishing swamp creatures
maybe i would have done very well it was
really incredible
to chat with him and see him work now
don't miss tonight's episode that
tribute at the end we mention
will be a minute and a half long
honoring alex
including clips from his earliest days
on the jeopardy stage with many of the
fun and playful moments
trebek had with contestants over the 37
years he hosted jeopardy
now again that tribute ends with the
dedication and it will say forever in
our hearts
always our inspiration very nice